all right so you've got the book you've  got a little bit of a raisin which i  really don't think you're going to  finish but you can go to town go to zone  also you have two drips  look over here you have two drips of  water you got an led flashlight in case  the power goes out you just got to step  on it like this see how whoa sorry well  don't stand right in front of it finally  this is the sparkler what you do is you  light this end on fire and then you step  back this can act as a flare all right  what would i need that's if you need a  signal for help and dean's gonna leave  you his phone just in case what was he  the first you know what now that i'm  thinking about it why don't we just put  the colander over you now if you want  okay how's that  you must let me out of here  you